[Musik]
jeder schmeckt fantastisch
das erinnert mich an ostern ostern ja in
unserer familie gab es schon oft hoch
laden zum mittagessen
es gab keinen hasenbraten einmal da war
ich noch sehr klein und dachte dass wir
den straßen essen
ich hoffe so gemeint ist meine eltern
seit diesem tag nie wieder ein nasen
braten gemacht haben
ostern war für mich als kind immer ein
tolles fest meine eltern haben über dem
garten bunter und und manchmal noch
schokolade versteckt und ich musste
suchen gab es bei euch zu ostern auch
und gefärbte eier natürlich aber mein
lieblings fest war immer weihnachten
brauchte bei euch der weihnachtsmann
oder das christkind die geschenke das
christkind ja bei uns aber die geschenke
waren nicht das wichtigste
ich habe mit meinem mann günter immer
den weihnachtsbaum geschmückt wir haben
jedes jahr im advent stollen gegessen
und die kerzen am adventskranz
angezündet
das glückte zwar schön aber allein
weihnachten ist kein schönes fest wenn
man allein ist
dann lasst es uns dort gemeinsam feiern
wenn nicht hier
lasst uns wegfahren ein weihnachts
abenteuer
meinst du das ernst
vollkommen herz das wäre schön
[Musik]